from calorie counter portion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between taco bell in the us
and the uk this is food wars
taco bell we're talking tacos at the us
taco bell you can get
an individual hard shell taco or
you can get three with
a drink and one with medium or you can
get a party pack
which is 12 get a load of this
it's like i'm presenting a newborn
[Laughter]
the serving sizes for tacos in the uk
are one individual taco
or
two tacos fries and a drink which is a
combo meal
this is a us beef taco supreme first
thing i'm gonna do is measure it
hang on oh man it's almost exactly
six inches all right let's weigh it
new scale
what is it oh over 100 grams this is a
crunchy beef taco supreme in the uk
it measures exactly five inches across
and it weighs 70 grams
wow that's way heavier what is that
this is a standard burrito in the uk
we've gone for crispy chicken i also one
with chicken
it measures six and a half inches in
length
you know what six and a half inches
weighs
about 210 grams uh 230.
here's our quesadilla it is yo
dude it's a foot 12 inches this is a uk
chicken quesadilla it measures 10 inches
in length
and it weighs
245 grams yeah about 245
weighs the same wider
crunchwrap supreme
this is a crunchwrap supreme in the uk
it measures
six inches points a point and it weighs
about 240 grams what's six cents without
looking it up
does anyone know what a six sided shape
is hey siri
what is a six-sided shape according to
giantbomb.com
regular hexagons hexagons
yo dude guess how many inches
six baby that is obviously that's on
purpose i wonder if there's
something about six sides six inches
if this thing weighs 666 grams i will
never not eat these
here we go
[Music]
275 for the hexagon
crunchwrap supreme six sides
six inches what's the biggest thing on
the uk menu
well for us it's the classic cravings
meal for six
in the us biggest thing on the menu
remember this guy
taco party pack the classic cravings
meal for six comes with
two quesadillas two beef crunch wrap
supremes
two volcano burritos two portions of
nachos belgrande
and then six beef tacos and three
portions of
cinnamon twists for dessert as you can
see it's just 12 tacos i know that seems
very simple but sometimes
simplicity is the best it's 12 tacos you
can get them either
hard shell or soft shell regular or
supreme
at least half of them i know you can get
as doritos tacos locos if you don't know
what that is you'll find a little later
here in the u.s
let's take a look at some of the
nutritional info for taco bell starting
with the basics
in the uk a plain crunchy beef taco
is 159 calories and has 308 milligrams
of sodium
in the u.s our crunchy beef taco is 170
calories
a chicken quesadilla in the uk is a
hefty 529 calories
our quesadilla actually has less
calories only 510
but it still has more sodium actually
has almost more than half
of your daily allowance third well in
the uk a crunchwrap has 578 calories
but shockingly it has 60 of your daily
saturated fat allowance
in the us our hexagram is 530 calories
and is about six grams of fat less than
the one in the uk
but surprised to know one ours has more
sodium
as is always the case in the us you have
to look at the beverages this right here
is a large mountain dew baja blast
this is 30 ounces of a liquid that is
the most unnatural green i've ever seen
it glows in the dark it's so bright when
i close my eyes you can still see it
like when you look at the sun
this beverage has over 420
calories that is ridiculous i gotta take
a sip
oh my god this has
roughly 110 grams of sugar
it's an absurd amount of sugar
oh god it's like it's horrible yet i'm
addicted to it so i wanted to see
exactly what 110 grams of sugar
looks like and to do so get on my face
we got this
and this
come on are you serious i'm not even
halfway there
yeah okay there we go this
is in that america
this is too much sugar i get it this
thing
it's just
ah man
i hate that so much
let's start with the ingredients for the
basics in the uk a flour tortilla
contains the following
fortified wheat flour made with wheat
flour calcium carbonate iron
niacin and thiamin water metabolism
e500 e450 and 1896 sugar e471
and a flour treatment agent e920.
here we go in the u.s our flour
tortillas have
enriched wheat flour water vegetable
shortening with soybean hydrogenated
soybean and or cottonseed oil
propionates that's a tough one soberic
acid
and or potassium sorbate
these lists might look quite different
but actually a lot of it's just down to
terminology
for example the uk menu tends to use e
numbers whereas the us menu tends to
refer to things by their full chemical
names
yeah it's a good distinction to make
harry but is it better i don't know what
sounds worse
e450 or pyrophosphates pyrophosphates is
a scary sounding chemical
e450 sounds like a star wars droid i
don't think it really makes much of a
difference personally what about some
meat options
well in the uk 72 of the beef is beef
and the rest is made up of beef fat
maltodextrin
tomato powder paprika cumin black pepper
salt chili powder garlic powder onion
powder
yeast extract oregano cocoa powder
flavor enhancer
e635 cellulose salt
stabilizers e451 and e452
and in the united states our beef
contains beef
imagine that water seasoning which is
cellulose
chili pepper maltodextrin salt oats soy
lecithin
spices tomato powder sugar onion powder
citric acid
natural flavors new set of brackets
including smoke flavor
clothesline brackets tarula yeast coca
disodium and ossiate and
what is this word guanulates
guanolinx what happens uh looks like
it's
pretty much the same thing you guys got
there in the uk one thing we need to
note about the us taco bell menu is that
items like the baja blast
and the doritos tacos locos i think the
shells
have an ingredient called yellow number
five uh yellow number five is not in the
uk
of course it's in the u.s in the uk you
usually find yellow five referred to as
tartrazine
it's on a list of six chemicals which
when added to food must contain the
following
warning may have an adverse effect on
activity and attention in children
and according to the fda in some cases
it causes itching
and hives in people who eat it
disgusting
itching and hives yup that's fine um hey
i ate a grown up and i'm perfectly fine
i should note that i have a full head of
gray hair and i just turned 23.
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk taco bell
this is everything you can only get at a
us taco bell
so we only have the one exclusive taco
and it's this one
which is the crispy chicken soft taco
what it is is pretty much just a
standard taco with the lettuce the
cheese the sour cream
but then we've kind of got one of these
breaded crispy chicken fillets in the
middle as well
first thing which is right in front of
me i've talked about this twice already
it is the party pack
uh we've already met the baja blast
oh man i hate it so much one thing
that i love a taco bell the doritos
locos tacos what is it it is a taco
that the shell is a dorito
see that made of the same stuff now we
actually have a bunch of exclusive
burrito options in the uk
we'll start with this one which is the
volcano burrito now apparently this used
to be on the menu in the us but is no
longer there
what it is is basically just like a beef
and rice burrito
there's some sour cream cheese in there
as well and some crunchy tortilla chips
and i think it gets the name volcano
because it's got the lava sauce in there
so it's quite spicy
yes harry the volcano burrito was
available in the u.s for a limited time
it was a promotional
menu item for the 1995
box office bomb congo based on the
michael crichton book
repeated my boy michael crichton here we
have a beefy nacho griller which is a
fantastic
name what this is is just beef and
crushed nacho chips with some cheese
sauce in a burrito
here we've got the double cheesy black
bean burrito
which as the name suggests has two types
of cheese it's got the nacho cheese
and also the shredded cheese in there as
well as some rice and black beans
here we have the seven layer burrito we
have another exclusive crispy chicken
option which is a
crispy chicken burrito and then finally
we have the spicy chicken
it's griller bad it does just kind of
taste like something that i could make
at home there's a bunch of burritos um
i'm gonna try and figure out what these
burritos are without like completely
ripping them apart
this right here oh beefcake cerrito
somehow they combined a burrito and a
quesadilla and has this
light brown brick if you don't want beef
you want to go
vegetarian they also have a black bean
quesarito
this looks like five layer burrito i
didn't know this until i had to do this
video but there's no seven layer burrito
in america anymore they took out two
layers
and i got the five layer one ah what is
this
well all these just look the same
grilled cheese burrito
sounds awesome i don't like grilled
cheese and
these two that are left here one of them
is a cheesy bean and rice burrito
and the other one is a burrito supreme
that's one of these two
i don't know which is which we also have
steak quesadillas which unfortunately
the taco bell that i went to did not
have them
this big thing right here i love this
look at this this is the nacho
party pack it's exactly what it sounds
like get a good look uk
this is what nachos are supposed to look
like now what we lack in nachos we more
than make up for in
fries we love fries in the uk obviously
we call them chips but it's very unusual
to walk into a fast food restaurant and
not be able to find them so i think taco
bell have kind of tried to cash in on
that in the uk basically your standard
fries
but then they have a kind of feta
seasoning on them as well you can get
them in three sizes
regular fries then you have the fries
supreme
and then finally you have the fry's
belgrande which is the biggest size
we ordered one deconstructed and one
constructed just to see the difference
mexican
pizza uh they were saying for a while
that these were going to be
taken off the menu we still got them in
a couple locations apparently
i got my hands on one look at this guy
um oh this right here the powerball the
protein bowl
this is actually a really good idea for
them it's just all protein
no carbs now the only side that seems to
be exclusive to the uk is actually just
a little bowl of rice
for some reason i couldn't find this on
the us menu if i was wrong let me know
what everyone in the uk
has been waiting for taco bell breakfast
yes
i think of all the fast food breakfasts
taco bells is the best these are the
items that you can get
here in america and they are all great a
cheesy toasted
breakfast burrito the hash brown
toasted burrito the
grande toasted breakfast burrito another
one i want to point out here
is the breakfast crunch wrap supreme
of course we all know this shape
hexagon they're like the regular
burritos you'd get at taco bell
but they have eggs in them sometimes
have bacon a pico de gallo
uh they're all very good very very good
i'm really sad that we don't have any
breakfast items in the uk
but what we do have is churros for
dessert
these can be served with a little pot of
dolce de leche to dip in
and honestly i'm shocked that you guys
don't have these
for the us taco bell desserts the one
thing we got here you can't get in the
uk
are these cinnabon delights they're like
little cinnamon balls you can get them
in either an order of 2 or 12 or any
number in between
oh my god there's cream inside of these
i was not expecting that
exclusive drinks in the u.s this one is
a dragon fruit freeze that was like a
slurpee
you can also get powerade they got fruit
punch powerade on tap
right here pink lemonade and uh for the
baja blast fiends they also have a baja
blast freeze
yuck in the u.s our taco bell also has
iced coffee and iced tea
you